La amenaza de la Inteligencia artificial
para la humanidad ha sido objeto de
obras de ciencia ficción de hace décadas
sin embargo estos argumentos fantasiosos
parecen estar cada día más cerca de
hacerse realidad y escuchamos las
advertencias de filósofos científicos y
trabajadores de la industria tecnológica
unas advertencias agudizadas a raíz de
la irrupción del chat jepp en nuestra
cotidianidad en 2022 una herramienta que
nos ha hecho cuestionar hasta qué punto
las habilidades humanas son
insustituibles o no Para abordar la
cuestión hablamos desde Madrid con idoia
Salazar y es fundador y presidenta del
observatorio del impacto social y ético
de la Inteligencia artificial señora
Salazar bienvenida directo América
Hola buenas tardes qué tal Cómo estáis
encantada de estar aquí muy bien también
señora Salazar primero que todo Cuáles
son los riesgos reales en particular de
continuar desarrollando la Inteligencia
artificial porque mucho se habla de los
riesgos pero no hay Claridad sobre A qué
nos realmente pues si yo a la hora de
abordar estos riesgos Es verdad que a
raíz de la irrupción de chaypiti esto ha
provocado que haya un conocimiento de
conocimiento masivo de la Inteligencia
artificial en primer lugar para entender
estos riesgos tenemos que entender Qué
es su sistema de Inteligencia artificial
al final un sistema de Inteligencia
artificial es un software Es una
herramienta de ayuda al ser humano que
lo que hace es procesar datos y extraer
conclusiones con dos habilidades
específicas por un lado la toma de
decisiones y por otro lado esta
capacidad que tienen estos sistemas de
poderlo hacer de manera Autónoma
teniendo en cuenta Esta cuestión y para
intentar entender estos riesgos hay que
conocer que la decisión de dejar a los a
estos sistemas de Inteligencia
artificial la toma de decisiones de
manera Autónoma la tenemos los humanos
es decir todos los riesgos que tiene
actualmente la Inteligencia artificial
los podemos evitar si los humanos si
nosotros ahora mismo ponemos medidas
adecuadas para poder llevar a esta una
prevención de riesgos en la actualidad
Pues hay ya mucho
estudiado en torno a la ética y La
regulación en la Inteligencia artificial
riesgos específicos pues aquellos por
ejemplo derivados del mal uso de los
datos de entrenamiento del sistema que
puede provocar una discriminación es
decir por poner un ejemplo Claro si
usamos un sistema de Inteligencia
artificial en un departamento de
recursos humanos para
poner personas dentro de para contratar
nuevo personal esto puede suponer que si
el sistema no ha sido bien entrenado
cojan simplemente el sistema decida
por ejemplo solamente a varones de
una determinada edad de un determinado
condición social Pero esto ocurre por un
mal entrenamiento humano de esos
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial es
decir los riesgos que tienen los
sistemas los provocamos al menos por
ahora los seres humanos por lo tanto hay
que focalizar nuevamente en el hacer un
buena buena formación a esta persona que
está entrenando a los sistemas hay que
hacer buenas labores de supervisión para
evitar todos estos riesgos que tiene la
Inteligencia artificial cuando salió el
chat el gpt nos hace Recuerda que hubo
toda una polémica en los sistemas de
educación de Estados Unidos de Europa
que prohibían este programa en las
instituciones educativas de primaria y
universidades por ejemplo cómo afectaría
la Inteligencia artificial a la
educación Qué habilidades debemos
cultivar y cuáles debemos relegar
exclusivamente a esta tecnología
pues sin duda yo creo que fue una
reacción lógica al final vemos una
herramienta que es capaz de escribir
textos igual que los seres humanos en el
mismo lenguaje natural que es el
lenguaje en el que nos comunicamos los
seres humanos y lo hace realmente de
manera muy eficiente la cuestión es que
esta esta herramienta específica tiene
una serie de reglas básicas que que le
hacen que tenga una implementación
masiva incluso entre los alumnos estas
tres reglas básicas es son que es muy
fácil de usar cualquier alumno sin que
nadie le enseñe sabe usar
Exactamente lo mismo que usar Google es
no requiere ningún tipo de habilidad
especial también tiene otra cualidad
específica que es muy barata en realidad
tiene una versión gratuita cualquier
persona puede acceder a ella y tiene
otra tercera característica que
considero
imprescindible en cualquier tecnología
de Gran impacto que es la utilidad
realmente ha demostrado tener de mucha
utilidad ya no solamente entre los
alumnos sino también entre entre los
profesionales que quieren empezar a
usarlo en sus tareas diarias qué es lo
que nos queda a nosotros Qué habilidades
tenemos que cultivar nosotros al final
Como he explicado al principio chatipití
y otro tipo de sistemas de Inteligencia
artificial se tienen que ver con una
herramienta de ayuda al ser humano es
decir igual que por ejemplo empleamos
las calculadoras para hacer para hacer
cálculos base y a partir de esos
cálculos nosotros hacer evolucionar las
matemáticas y otro tipo de cálculos a
través de la supercomputación y otro
tipo de habilidades que tienen también
los humanos y que los humanos tenemos
que seguir aplicando a las matemáticas
Igualmente con estos modelos del
lenguaje nos dan una base sobre la que
nosotros podemos seguir incrementando
nuestra creatividad y nuestra
productividad junto con estos textos
base la conclusión es que hay que
aprender a usarla la conclusión no es en
ningún caso prohibir una tecnología que
es realmente útil y el resto de guías
alternativas ya han demostrado que son
útiles para la sociedad en todos los
sentidos no solamente para los
estudiantes sino también incluso para el
campo creativo incluso para para
cualquier tipo de empresa puede estar
usando Ya esta tecnología para mejorar
su productividad y por lo tanto no hay
que prohibirla hay que aprender a usarla
qué es lo que debemos hacer pues
cultivar habilidades también hay que
cultivar espíritu crítico hay que
cultivar esa convivencia con las
máquinas hay que saber
discernir entre entre sustitución de un
texto por ejemplo de un informe o de
algo hecho por nosotros que ahora lo
hagan las máquinas a una
complementariedad se trata de usar la
guía como una herramienta que nos dé una
base sobre la que seguir nosotros
aplicando nuestro conocimiento como
humanos ahora usted mencionaba por
ejemplo esta necesidad de aprender a
utilizar este tipo de herramientas y
muchos expertos coinciden en esto que no
es necesario prohibirla y hay un temor
generalizado y por ejemplo la
Inteligencia artificial podría
reemplazarnos pero estos expertos
también coinciden en que la gente que va
a ser reemplazada es aquella que no
llega a aprender a utilizar la
Inteligencia artificial cuéntenos en hay
algunos oficios que estarían en riesgo
de desaparecer muy brevemente por favor
que ya estamos llegando al final del
programa sí Yo diría que todos estamos
todo aquí el persona todo aquel oficio
que realmente toda aquella persona que
no se adapte independientemente del
oficio en el que esté está en riesgo la
clave está en la adaptabilidad la
Inteligencia artificial va a afectar
absolutamente todos los las profesiones
y por lo tanto todo el gran riesgo de
cualquier profesión de cualquier tarea
será el que no realmente esa persona
especifican no se adapte no asuma este
tipo de tecnologías para seguir
evolucionando habrá tareas específicas
en riesgo pero yo diría que no
profesiones y la clave está en que todos
los profesionales se pongan a aprender
Esas reglas esas nuevas normas de
convivencia para seguir realmente
evolucionando en su profesión
y presidenta del observatorio del
impacto social y ético de la
Inteligencia artificial Gracias por
acompañarnos con el análisis aquí en
directo América un placer Muchas gracias
Y ustedes televidentes también gracias
por acompañarnos no se desconecten que
minutos regresamos con más noticias esto
es directo América
[Música]